Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Cecilia Bernabeni
[Azione chiama, genera,
crea, ispira azione]
[Il conto alla rovescia
non lascia scampo]
[Possiamo fermare
il cambiamento climatico]
Buon pomeriggio.
Io ho deciso di vivere
tra gli esseri più forti e fragili
che ci sono nel pianeta Terra,
che sono gli alberi.
Nel senso che gli alberi hanno il potere -
alcuni - di avere una vita millenaria:
sono in grado di resistere
al freddo, al vento e al gelo.
Però sono degli esseri
che sono estremamente fragili,
nel senso che non possono
essere spostati dal luogo d'origine
e spesso non riescono
a reagire alla malasorte.
Popolano da sempre le campagne;
ma gli antichi prati
sembra che stiano retrocedendo
di fronte al cemento.
E vivendo in un luogo del genere,
come si può capire,
questo paradiso verde che mi sono creato,
si può avere la nostalgia,
anzi la strana sensazione
di avere la nostalgia
di un passato che non si è mai vissuto.
Questa sensazione è stata resa possibile
dai racconti di mio papà Giancarlo,
che è un antico agricoltore
di Parma, che ha 88 anni.
Giancarlo, chiaramente,
la maggior parte di voi,
se non pochissimi,
non lo conoscete, non lo potete conoscere.
Mio padre, per identificare
un attimo il soggetto,
è molto molto simile,
anzi quasi una sorta di alter ego,
del grande scrittore veneto
Mario Rigoni Stern, sapete?
Quello che scrisse
"Il sergente nella neve",
un mirabile romanzo
nel quale veniva descritta
la discesa, la dipartita degli alpini
dal fronte del Don,
che andavano poi in Italia
durante la Seconda Guerra Mondiale,
durante la ritirata della Russia.
Ma non scrisse solo questo componimento:
ma ne fece anche altri,
come per esempio "Uomini, boschi e api"
e l'"Arboreto selvatico".
Da tutti questi scritti traspare
in maniera lampante, evidente,
il profondo amore
che lo scrittore veneto aveva
non solo nei riguardi
del suo altopiano di Asiago,
ma nei confronti dei boschi,
e nei confronti soprattutto degli alberi.
Ed è lo stesso amore
che mio papà Giancarlo
ha avuto fin da bambino,
e ha maturato in età adulta,
perché qui inizio anch'io:
una ventina d'anni fa
decidemmo di mettere a dimora,
come è stato già precisato,
attraverso dei fondi comunitari,
4.000 alberi.
In una maniera,
direi, abbastanza difforme
rispetto a quello che è l'agricoltura,
l'attività agricola ordinaria
nella mia regione d'appartenenza.
Io infatti vengo da Parma,
dalla Regione Emilia Romagna.
Vi ho detto, inizialmente,
che io sono nostalgico
di un passato che non ho mai vissuto.
Forse la definizione più pugnace
che ho avuto modo di assorbire
nella mia vita di lettore
di nostalgia
la diede un filosofo tedesco
agli inizi del Novecento,
che disse che "la nostalgia è il dolore
della vicinanza del lontano".
È una sorta di dolore quello che mi prese,
allorché mio papà
mi fece vedere una fotografia.
Questa fotografia mostra una cerimonia,
una cerimonia che è una fotografia
in bianco e nero degli anni '40,
durante la Seconda Guerra Mondiale;
e mostra una cerimonia che si dipana
lungo la principale arteria
della mia frazione:
infatti abito a sette km
dal centro storico di Parma.
E al di là del fatto
che se non c'era mio padre
facevo veramente fatica a ricostruire
l'esatta ubicazione del luogo,
quello che mi è apparso
veramente straordinario,
e però mi ha profondamente amareggiato,
è il grande decoro estetico, spirituale,
culturale prima che ambientale,
intendetemi bene,
che c'era ai lati della via Emilia.
C'è tutto questo straordinario
paesaggio campestre
che era rappresentato
dai filari di gelsi, dai fossi,
dai fossati e dai vigneti;
e forse dal più antico esempio
di biodiversità inconsapevole
che era la "piantata" emiliana.
In cui c'era il vitigno
che semplicemente era accostato
con l'acero campestre, con l'olmo;
e questo sosteneva i filari.
Ecco: questo paesaggio,
nel corso di tre, quattro generazioni
è andato tramontato,
completamente tramontato
attraverso un'attività cementificatoria
che non ha avuto precedenti,
che ha avuto proprio
caratteri eccezionali.
E qui sollevo una piccola
polemica personale
in relazione a tutte
quelle lamentazioni che io vedo
in ordine alle sventure a distanza
di carattere ambientale, botanico,
fuori dall'Italia - che sono legittime
peraltro, assolutamente:
però penso che sia altrettanto legittimo
accorgerci della trave
che abbiamo nell'occhio,
in quanto l'azione cementificatoria,
piratesca, predatoria
ai danni della meravigliosa
campagna italiana,
campagna emiliana,
non ha avuto precedenti.
Io vengo da Parma:
e un mio conterraneo, Bernardo Bertolucci,
quando nel 1976 diresse "Novecento",
non è solo la descrizione
di due saghe familiari,
ma è soprattutto un grande omaggio,
uno straordinario omaggio
a questa bellezza che è andata perduta.
Una campagna emiliana che,
soprattutto nelle zone periurbane,
è stata quasi completamente cementificata,
perdendo una delle sue
caratteristiche prioritarie
che era uno dei suoi patrimoni:
che è quello dei corridoi,
delle funzioni ecologiche,
divenendo una sorta di eterna periferia
quasi indefinibile.
Io sono stato convocato davanti a voi
per spronarvi a una call to action,
per spronarvi a piantare degli alberi.
Io ho iniziato 20 anni fa,
ne ho piantati tanti,
ne ho piantati più di 15.000.
Piantare un albero dovrebbe essere -
intuitivamente lo capiamo tutti,
ma non in via esclusiva -
un atto proiettato nei confronti
del futuro, giustamente;
ma si deve impostare,
questo principio, sulla fede.
Cioè nel senso che noi diamo la vita
a degli esseri che molto probabilmente
ci sopravviveranno.
E non vi vorrei apparire paradossale
quando vi dico un'altra cosa:
io ho piantato 15.000 alberi
perché volevo proteggere il mio passato,
il nostro passato, il vostro passato.
E fateci caso: che nel passato,
il passato stesso come era conservato?
Attraverso i libri,
conservati a loro volta
nelle teche delle biblioteche:
ma libri e biblioteche essi stessi
sono fatti di materia arborea.
Ma questo pensiero, nato recentemente
ma l'idea nasce
da una situazione particolare
che ebbi modo di avere
all'età di dieci anni.
Io ritengo veramente
di diritto di appartenere -
sono un super parmigiano,
ritengo di appartenere alla famiglia
dei mammiferi stanziali, proprio.
E io avevo sempre l'abitudine
di girare per i miei campi,
di peregrinare,
finché mi imbattei in un manufatto.
Un manufatto che, dopo qualche anno,
ho saputo essere
un manufatto archeologico.
Questo è un frammento metallico
di un deposito votivo,
di un deposito cultuale.
Siamo nell'età del Ferro, siamo al momento
della infiltrazione etrusca
nella mia regione,
nella cosiddetta "Etruria padana" -
ma questo non ci deve interessare.
La cosa straordinaria
è che questo frammento faceva parte
di un deposito fatto di lingotti di rame.
Lingotti di rame
che recano impresso un segno -
è un segno di fusione,
il segno del ramoscello secco -
che venivano buttati
all'interno delle paludi.
Ma la cosa veramente eccezionale,
ed è straordinaria,
è che questo metallo preziosissimo
veniva volutamente adulterato
con la presenza del ferro.
E questo ci dà il punto
di riferimento finale,
cioè nel senso che questo era
un atto di omaggio
nei confronti di una divinità
che si considerava presente
all'interno di quella polla d'acqua.
Una divinità lacustre.
Evidentemente, questo terreno
aveva una specifica destinazione
in un lontano passato,
votiva, cultuale, forse anche sacrale.
E io mi ricordo, quando feci
la tesi in diritto romano,
mi ricordo perfettamente questo termine:
delle "res sacrae"
cioè di quelle cose che sono sottratte
alla libera disponibilità dell'uomo.
Una cosa che mi è rimasta
pietrificata nella testa.
E adesso è il momento
di fare a voi una domanda:
quali sono quelle cose, quelle res,
sottratte alla libera
disponibilità dell'uomo?
Quali sono quelle cose sottratte
alla logica speculativa del mercato?
Quali sono quelle cose
che non si vendono e non si comprano?
La risposta è semplice: niente.
Si può vendere tutto,
si può comprare tutto.
Ma questa è stata
l'esatta identica domanda
che, per tre o quattro anni,
tutti gli esimi rappresentanti
del "mondo di mezzo" dell'immobiliare -
gli agenti, gli speculatori,
gli affaristi, i procacciatori,
le società, le imprese
di costruzione mi hanno fatto:
ma perché lei, Spaggiari,
che ha 70.000 metri quadrati
di terra agricola
che è diventata potenzialmente
edificabile, non vende?
Ma perché non lo deve fare?
E allora, io ho cominciato
a farmi qualche domanda.
La situazione era molto particolare,
nel senso che, come avete visto,
l'area aveva una sua
specifica vocazione sacrale.
Questa situazione era nata
anche con la presenza di mia madre,
che adesso non c'è più.
Noi eravamo tutti coinvolti
in tutto questo pensiero
di non volere alterare
tutto quello che era un'area
che era nostra da tempo.
Decidemmo di fare
un'azione molto particolare,
nel senso che io seguo fin da vicino
un grande letterato tedesco, Ernst Jünger,
che raccontava una cosa,
nel suo "Trattato del Ribelle":
se ti vuoi sottrarre ai dettami,
ai legacci della società,
devi ritornare nei confronti del bosco.
Cosa è stato questo ritorno al bosco?
È stato un ritorno al bosco
che non è stato fatto fuor di metafora,
ma è stato fatto materialmente.
Infatti noi, attraverso una piccola
combriccola di amici,
abbiamo messo su con due vanghe,
una zappa, un filo,
abbiamo voluto piantare
e mettere in ordine
altri 7036 alberi:
e questo ha comportato
un effetto assolutamente straordinario,
perché là dove doveva esserci
il solito quartiere residenziale,
adesso c'è una famiglia di istrici.
Là dove doveva esserci il solito cemento,
adesso appunto, come si può vedere,
c'è un enorme bacino verde
di circa 15.000 alberi per 13 ettari,
con un vincolo ambientale di destinazione
che vorrei fosse perenne.
Perché questa, come vedete,
non è legname da ardere ma è materia viva.
E l'altra cosa straordinaria:
là dove doveva esserci il solito asfalto,
in realtà adesso c'è
una fervente socialità,
cioè nel senso che quasi tutti i pomeriggi
lasciamo lì delle frotte di bambini,
perché io ho voluto rendere l'area libera,
l'ho voluta rendere
accessibile a chiunque.
Cioè non ho voluto creare, erigere,
delle palizzate,
delle recinzioni, dei muri.
L'ho lasciato libero -
e questo ha avuto
un ulteriore effetto positivo.
Pensate al periodo che abbiamo vissuto:
c'è stato il lockdown,
poi c'è stata la graduale riapertura
dell'Italia all'inizio di maggio.
Questo ha avuto un profondo
ristoro spirituale
nei confronti delle persone
che hanno transitato a lungo
nei miei campi,
ne hanno avuto un grandissimo beneficio.
E di questo me ne sono compiaciuto,
nel senso che io ho scritto una lettera,
davo menzione di questo mio sentimento
nei confronti di questi
avventori, di questi amici,
dicendo loro due cose molto semplici:
non lasciate incuria
dopo il vostro passaggio;
ma soprattutto, proteggete gli alberi,
proteggete la campagna.
La stessa campagna che invoca a voi
l'esercizio del suo diritto principale.
Che è quello del silenzio,
in quanto qui vige il regno degli alberi.
E allora, perché io
e mio padre l'abbiamo fatto?
Non certo perché siamo dei folli,
o perché siamo persone
particolarmente generose, o coraggiose,
o così improvvide da rinunciare
a un'elevata somma di denaro.
Non l'abbiamo fatto per tutto questo:
semplicemente, qui c'è una seconda domanda
che potrei fare a voi:
ma la terra, ritenete veramente
che sia un luogo?
Pensateci.
La Terra è un luogo?
La Terra è un essere.
E la naturale preghiera
che questo essere rivolge a noi
è quello della cura,
è quello dell'attenzione
e soprattutto è quello della semplicità.
Cura, attenzione e semplicità.
Ed è una naturale preghiera
che penso ognuno di noi possa accogliere.
Grazie.
(Applausi)